This is the new Microsoft Surface.
It embodies the notion of hardware and software really pushing each other.
People do want to create and consume.
They want to work and they want to play.
They want to be on their couch, they want to be at their desk...
...and they want to be on the go.
Surface is super thin at 9.3 millimeters. It's just thin enough for this full-size USB port,...
...for peripherals or just charging your phone while you're at the hotel.
The edges are beveled away at 22 degrees so the PC itself fades into the background.
It feels natural in your hands.
Surface is the first PC with a full magnesium case.
Through a unique process, the liquid metal is formed into an ultra rigid yet ultralight frame.
It is incredibly strong. And it's airy at under 1.5 pounds, just 676 grams.
And it's finely balanced.
We think that a stand should be integral so we built a stand into the device.
Let me attach the cover. Click. You heard that, it's solid.
Click.
Close the cover, it's integrated into the device.
It's made from a fine Northwest polar tech.
It feels great in your hand, like a book. It just fits there.
Why shouldn't we just take this surface and make it a full multi-touch keyboard?
This touch cover is not just a multi-touch keyboard,...
...but it's a modern trackpad with left and right buttons.
It even has the keys for the Windows 8 Metro style UI.
This keyboard, combined with the kickstand, form the hallmark of just hands-on creativity.